you tell us anything about season six I
mean I'm not obviously not looking for
spoilers here but just anything about
the mood of the show or anything that
you can tell us it's gonna be come out
there's a lot of conflicts happening
inside and outside those walls there's a
lot of mistrust there's a lot of Morgan
yeah there's this there's there's so
much going on right now it's it's um
even off the first episode it's it's so
powerful in all these different
directions and full of tense energy that
all of us just went straight into it
just grinding our teeth and you can feel
it you can see you don't say that a lot
of sadness there's a rumor that's very
prevalent that one of you doesn't get
out of this season alive there's always
rumors this is more than just people say
that about you and me before
it's guess what it's been pretty sketchy
there a couple of we are so thrilled
that we know you're really busy but
having you guys here is absolute magic
thank you so much The Walking Dead
returns October 11th on AMC we'll be
right back stories of Game of Thrones
going to be here
[Applause]